come or more people gathering now
because we're just about to reach the
point where we'll get our first contact
everything is a little bit delay the
further north you go we're around about
10 minutes behind at what you've been
seen in their first of all in Spain and
then of course in the UK as well but we
had a moment of excitement about five or
six minutes ago when we saw the Sun for
the first time it has been a pretty
depressing morning with a lot of rain a
lot of great cloud and then suddenly the
Sun broke through for a few minutes we
were all able to get our glasses out and
take a look and think oh we might be on
for something exciting after all and it
really will be a complete lottery
because there are times this morning
where we have seen great big patches of
blue sky and you just want that blue sky
to coincide with the moment that the Sun
is reaching its a total eclipse and the
Sun right on has come out and we can see
it now now if it was to be like this in
just over an hour's time we would have
the best per meter on land where you can
witness a total eclipse one of them is
here on the Faroe Islands and the other
is in the far north of Norway so I ran
about ten thousand tourists have
supplemented the population of 50,000
here to try to get the views people and
I start to come down they're bringing
their cameras a lot of people had have
been able to in terms of the cruise
liners in two planes and then accursed
people have been sore doing last-minute
journeys as well but the forecasts all
week has been pretty gloomy nobody
thought they would really be able to see
anything even some of the cruise liners
which were moored up overnight in the
harbor here in the capital Travon up
tanker and I moved elsewhere to try to
get a better view but it is a gamble I
mean who would be the captain of a
cruise liner that took a thousand
passengers further out to sea and they
saw nothing the people where they had
been where we are now got the view oh
it's a tough job trying to be able to
keep an eye on these eclipses isn't it